[A] All right, everyone.
[A] Today,.
[A] I have a very great news.
[A] We are about to speak with our first coordinator on mainnet.
[A] So if you guys were following Crunch a couple of weeks back,.
[A] We introduced this new role on testnet called the coordinators. And coordinators are other entities in the world of decentralized AI that would like to tap into the power of Crunch.
[A] And the first coordinator that reached mainnet, meaning that managed.
[A] Managed to develop the smart contract necessary to interact with Crunch is called Synth and I am here in New York with his founder,.
[A] James.
[A] How are you, James?
[A] It's great to have you here.
[B] Thank you. And thank you for having me in this beautiful office.
[B] It's super cool.
[A] Today,.
[A] The main subject is the Synth coordinator.
[A] So first and foremost.
[A] What are you guys building,.
[A] Gents,.
[A] On this subnet and what kind of product are you actually putting out out of it?
[B] Yeah,.
[B] So Synth is essentially a probabilistic intelligence layer for asset prices.
[B] So we focus very much on getting people to forecast price path distributions versus trying to forecast just individual prices in the future,.
[B] Which is.
[B] Is pretty common um for most kind of like yeah finance competitions trading competitions a lot a lot of them are focused on like point predictions um some point in the future and we're focused on distributions so you know you've really got to try and forecast where the price will go and how it will go there um so yeah uh the competition is um based on Bittensor as a subnet.
[B] Um,.
[B] Competitors,.
[B] Uh,.
[B] Submit a thousand paths or Monte Carlo simulations,.
[B] Um,.
[B] Every hour on a continuous basis and are scored on, uh,.
[B] How accurate their distributions are to the actual price. So it's live, it's ongoing.
[B] Um,.
[B] And yeah,.
[B] Super excited to, you know,.
[B] Expand,.
[B] Um,.
[B] The different people that can access the competition by working with Crunch.
[A] It's super exciting because we are particularly fan of these approaches that are more probabilistic instead of, you know, predicting price.
[A] And actually,.
[A] I don't agree.
[A] A lot of people make that mistake and try to predict price and end up in this very,.
[A] Very noisy environment that is extremely hard to model.
[A] Whereas here you had two layers,.
[A] Not only you try to predict a distribution of price,.
[A] But you also had many vectors with many.
[A] Researcher and so my next question would be how did you end up in this setup why did you choose to go for decentralized AI setup and why is it making so much sense for a product like that.
[B] We've spent a lot of time being my co-founder Sam, like building out different trading systems,.
[B] Especially in crypto decentralized finance.
[B] We've also competed in competitions in the past like Numerai competition.
[B] And we really like the idea that, you know, you can get you can crowdsource intelligence.
[B] And for us there,.
[B] You know, around a year ago,.
[B] We started to think about what would agents and LLMs that are going to be like the primary users of markets in the future, what do they need?
[B] And they already have access to like all the historical data they could want.
[B] And they're very good at answering questions about historical data.
[B] But LLMs agents aren't very good at answering questions about the future so can you create this intelligence layer that they can tap into to answer questions better about the future and for this you want to have um get an open competition or you want to have a lot of competitors um who can kind of create a really robust um data layer intelligence layer that people can tap into and yeah um.
[B] For that you need to have a very transparent scoring mechanism you need to make sure it's fair and you need to make sure the participants are well paid and yeah we think we've achieved a lot of those things with synth and we now have a very competitive environment.
[B] With high reward like roughly around a hundred thousand dollars per month in rewards going out to participants which is cool um and we have really strong data sets that yeah agents can tap into but we've also seen like.
[B] Trading firms,.
[B] Different traders,.
[B] People who do risk management also tapping into this data.
[B] Um and you can apply it to like options markets prediction markets and yeah it's cool.
[A] It's a very complex problem to solve.
[A] I think people don't realize that when you come in the market and you try to build a quant algorithm or you try to predict market,.
[A] You actually compete with a huge team of quant and researchers with other company that are injecting millions, if not hundreds of millions every year in mine every little bit of information that can help them.
[A] Them trying to understand you know what will be this distribution of returns and etc and so i think in your setup there is not only the stability but also the predictive power and alpha that you can get from there because you can attract people from you know.
[A] Vast different background and by the way guys you don't need to understand finance to do and to compete at Crunch at Crunch and at Synth on the coordinator of Synth on Crunch it's just pure price distribution like you look at time series kind of and and of course you can inject a lot of other kind of feature and maybe that's something you want to touch base.
[A] We didn't talk about the scoring.
[A] You mentioned the reward.
[A] Maybe quick word on the scoring. How do you assess the best submission?
[A] What is the scoring metrics and how do you really?
[A] Prevail on top of people that try to actually cheat the subnet or cheat the coordinator.
[B] Yeah, so we use continuous rank probability scoring system. So you're continuously ranked on how close your distributions are to the actual price movement.
[B] And this rewards people who are confident and like very confident in their distribution and are correct.
[B] It punishes people who are confident and incorrect.
[B] And people who are vague, the more vague you are, the more likely you are to have a very mediocre score.
[B] And the subnet is weighted to people who have, you know, accurate predictions,.
[B] Accurate forecasts of distributions,.
[B] They receive the most rewards.
[B] So yeah,.
[B] It's quite hard to cheat.
[B] There's also like a negative cost.
[B] So if you try and do things like register lots of participants,.
[B] Then.
[B] Um it's very unlikely that will be successful some will get deregistered and there's a cost to that um so yeah we found that like the scoring mechanism has kind of evolved over time it's got a lot more robust um and yet it's it's in a in a great position right now so yeah people should uh you know we call it like a proper scoring rule like the best you know the the optimal strategy is to try and really um.
[B] Try and be as accurate as possible from the very beginning and just improve your model over time. And it's very likely you're going to do well.
[A] It's live scoring. So there is there is it's the best protection against any kind of of cheating,.
[A] Right? And,.
[B] Exactly.
[A] You know, we were having this discussion before where we said,.
[A] Okay, you can have a very hard training and you're going to be scored on live data on a live ring with everyone else looking at you.
[A] And so if you fake the training or you overfit, you know, the data set.
[A] Said you're going to get destroyed on the ring there is no there is no shortcut like live market was to call your algorithm the way you would have been scored on a proper trading strategy and on top of that you have yeah I guess people can choose their strategy but you have these negative incentives in the mining slot and so guys don't worry because I know you're not used to that crunch is working a lot on reputation for a long time and we're a bit more paternalist let's say so we will kind of help.
[A] Help people in building meta model out of all the submission on crunch and then submit this meta models into mining slots except of course if someone is like really performing alone on crunch then we'll probably plug him directly into things because in the end crunch try to solve that right the complexity of opening a mining slot of paying for the mining slots maybe you can try more things on crunch because you won't have you know the time to test and the money.
[A] That you're gonna do so you can be a bit more creative maybe and end up participating in mining without the negative incentive you still have to build your reputation on crunch and for that reason we have this one month warm-up during which we will just look at the submission and the model before actually starting registering mining slots into synth.
[B] I think that's what we love about working with Crunch is that.
[B] It's making the the subnet more expect more accessible making the competition much more accessible um and we're discussing as well earlier like there's so many more tools available now and you don't have to be um an expert in finance by any means um to enter the competition right especially through crunch you can.
[B] You know just have skills from different industries and this is a great place to learn about yeah time series Monte Carlo simulations and modeling so yeah it's very exciting.
[A] Well, believe me, it's not easy. It's exciting but.
[B] Yeah.
[A] Not easy. So we started to look a bit at the, you know, what were the performance of the different miner on your subnet. And your product will be as good as the best prediction or the best ensemble you can have over there.
[A] Because that's very, this kind of anchor of a price that then allows you to build whatever you could on top.
[B] Yeah.
[A] The level is pretty high and you had one good archetype of that performance with what you did on prediction market.
[A] That I think is just brilliant.
[A] Do you want to talk about it?
[B] Yeah, absolutely.
[B] So firstly,.
[B] Like it is very competitive, like because the prices are significant.
[B] That's roughly like 80 to $100,000 per month in rewards going out to participants. So yeah,.
[B] The prizes are significant.
[B] So yeah, there is a lot of competition.
[A] Real player coming in.
[B] Yeah,.
[A] Yeah.
[B]
[B] Real players are coming in. And yeah,.
[B] Some of them have also worked at, you know.
[B] Various places where they've got some experience with this but.
[B] Yeah the the the quality of the data over the last few months has improved like a lot um we ran an experiment on polymarket um where we're trading some binary binary up down yes yes no up down markets um and we had an account i think it started around 3000 turned into 60 to 70 000 um and yeah i mean recently like that was cool.
[B] Recently we've seen some interesting behavior on the market,.
[B] On Polymarket.
[B] So we created a dashboard, we created some tools so people can...
[B] Yeah use uh or they can you know see if there's any discrepancies between Synth's probabilistic forecasts and the Polymarket prices um on certain markets um which can help them with their own trading so yeah uh we're also very excited about yeah.
[A] You mentioned that point in particular,.
[A] You mentioned discrepancy, like you figure out something that is interesting,.
[A] I think the anecdote.
[B] Yeah yeah we saw last last uh week around a week ago.
[B] Um someone was moving the price of BTC to try and win markets um they also moving the price of XRP you know just like 10 20 seconds before the end of the market um and we were seeing a lot of discrepancy in you know.
[B] This potentially caused a lot of like automated systems that didn't have like this level of data to lose money so yeah we think that like probabilistic forecasts that they can be useful for a huge amount of kind of yeah things across trading across risk management you can you know integrate this data into like automated trading systems options market so yeah.
[B] There's a lot of applications,.
[B] But as you said,.
[B] The key is to have a great competition so really great strong robust data comes out of it.
[A] I think the outcome of that,.
[A] The proof that you have is you've been correctly predicting the direction of one of the assets you're tracking.
[A] Yeah,.
[A] A certain amount of time, like to take that icon from that point to where you end up.
[A] Okay, prediction market aren't perfect and you know there's plenty of way to game that.
[A] But cool article guys, by the way, go and check it out. I think you published it on your Twitter.
[A] Yeah,.
[A] So taking it from there,.
[A] Where do you see, where do you see, you mentioned like option pricing, you mentioned, you know, retail traders, where do you see taking synth data,.
[A] What else?
[A] Where do you see most traction?
[B] I think like we've seen like we've seen a lot of demand for crypto data,.
[B] But we've added equities and we think that there's going to be a huge amount of demand for like 24-7 data across equities as we see like stock exchanges that they're all moving to become 24-5.
[A] New York Stock Exchange announced last week.
[B] Exactly. Yeah.
[B] Yeah.
[B] So 24 hour trading is coming,.
[B] No sleep in 2026.
[A] We've been having 25.
[B] Yeah, we didn't have in.
[A] I.
[B] 2025.
[A] Mean, we've been crypto since like maybe 10 years.
[B] Yeah, too long.
[A] I'm used to see market going on weekend anyway.
[B] Exactly,.
[B] Exactly.
[B] So like, there's gonna be this big regime shift,.
[B] Right where equities come onchain,.
[B] I think probabilistic data is going to become a lot more important.
[B] And we're seeing a lot of demand for this people,.
[B] Yeah, using the data within like risk management systems within trading systems.
[B] I also think that the way that we have like this new.
[B] Kind of group of pro retail traders emerging so people who have started using different tools like different technologies to start trading so maybe it's you know building their own algorithms or maybe they're using Claude to create like more complex trading strategies than they used to have maybe they're integrating different data sets into their trading strategies I think this trend is going to continue over the the coming year.
[B] Um and so yeah there'll be more demand for probabilistic data for sure um i think it's creating like this perfect storm um so yeah we're in a good position but yeah no sleep in 2026.
[A] So maybe last word on that.
[A] So we're going to mine in this coordinator probabilistic return of a few cryptocurrency,.
[A] Precious metals.
[A] A few equity as.
[B] It sounds.
[A] Well that.
[B] Yeah.
[A] You bring again.
[A] Right now,.
[A] Where do you see the, are you going to add more like time series or more like assets?
[A] At which speed?
[A] How do you move forward with that?
[B] Good question.
[B] In total, we have nine assets,.
[B] So we may add more in the future.
[B] Like we may also um like we like our goal is to create this like uh this kind of broad intelligence layer right um so we definitely will add some more assets kind of based on demand um we're seeing like silver is in demand right now it's had great performance recently so potentially adding in silver models in the future we might add in more equities um we're pretty open.
[B] Uh to kind of responding to demand but right now we've just added in some equity so we'll make sure that performance is good there um and then yeah we'll see in the near future.
[A] The cruncher that are listening and what kind of tips you can give I give them like what do you think the most performing miners are actually doing and.
[B] Yes so i think like the key thing is to really think about like this is a volatility modeling competition um.
[B] Volatility is based on multiple factors,.
[B] But right now.
[B] Volatility is very much based on different news events so reacting to those news events or having ways to bring that data into your model is very important.
[A] Fitting a famous president,.
[B] Yeah.
[A] Right?
[B] Exactly so news is moving the market significantly so yeah I think it's key to like try and bring in different news news feeds social media data into your models that can really help performance.
[A] And so right now within the game.
[A] We're going to be providing data from Pyth,.
[A] Right?
[A] What.
[B] Yeah.
[A] Kind.
[A] Of data are you providing natively?
[B] So Pyth Pyth is the the price data um and the yeah the oracle we use it's very robust they're uh yeah they have a great system but yeah for your modeling like.
[B] You know, you can explore different data sets,.
[B] Right? As many different data sets as possible.
[A] Yeah.
[B] And yeah,.
[B] You mentioned that that's also now possible.
[A] That's a new feature on Crunch,.
[A] By the way, since it's going to be the first time, guys, where when you submit your model into the TE,.
[A] You'll be able to also access external data.
[A] So you can have, you know, kind of API calls within the trusted execution environment and, you know, fetch data from, I don't know, maybe you have a proprietary data set somewhere.
[A] Where maybe you have some scraping that you have been doing here and then or maybe you know you have a validator in this particular protocol whether you know when you're gonna I don't know if you already had a soul is not yet into the you.
[B] Solana.
[A] Have you have Ethereum Bitcoin and and.
[B] So.
[A] So okay perfect maybe you're running some application that runs that maybe you deep into some other networks and you have some information I'm sure some people.
[A] I would love to be able to do that and that's a first on crunch so.
[B] Amazing.
[A] It's good we needed to anyway because there is.
[A] Only a limited information of only limited amount of alpha in price data right and and like we said it's been massively mine anyway so maybe you can go deeper with models uh but i think it's better to go orthogonal and find new ideas on your data sets on your feature set uh for sure all right james this is super exciting uh we are extremely happy i think it's it could not we could not dream about a better coordinator here.
[A] It's really aligned with what we like, what we believe in.
[A] There is massive rewards, guys.
[A] We talk about like 100K a month.
[A] So it's unseen,.
[B] That's, yeah.
[A] Unseen,.
[A] But also very competitive,.
[A] But we like that anyway.
[A] Guys, I really encourage you if you are a trader, a trading desk,.
[A] If you need some pricing data,.
[A] I think Synth is going to provide some very, very interesting vectors and great insight in your trading infrastructure or in your strat. So.
[A] So really check this out on their website if you are a cruncher in the coming days maybe it's already released by the moment we release this video you should see on crunchdao.com slash competition slash Synth as a Synth competition we're gonna open a Discord channel where we will be able to exchange and ask questions and etc feel free to go and join James' community as well on their own Discord if you want to go deeper but I think after the first months of warm-up.
[A] Would be great to have you again and maybe check out where we actually are on the leaderboard and start phase two with the mining operation.
[B] Awesome.
[B] Let's do it.
[B] Super excited.
[A] All right, let's go.
[B] Thank you so much.
[A] Good day everyone.
[A] Bye-bye.